[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICLAS KROGER: So we started talking
to the mayor of Bandung in 2016
when he wanted to make Bandung a
more livable city, a more happy city
and increase the happiness
index of its citizens.
So we first got in contact
with him through one
of his partners, the guy who was leading
the smart city initiative of Bandung.
So we began talking and
really had a lot of discussion
of how we can include the citizens
into creating new innovations,
into getting involved in
making the city more livable.
So we decided to go for
a crowdsourcing contest
because Indonesia is really an
interesting market in this regard.
They are really keen on using social
media and these kind of platforms
to communicate.
So I think, around
that time, Jakarta was
announced to be the number one
tweeting city in the world.
So really the social media usage
in this country was really high.
So it was a great way to
connect different people
and to collect a lot of different ideas
and problems on an online platform.
So really [? this ?] kind
of pre-existing conditions
in the community allowed
us to use this method.
And we really wanted to understand
what moved these people, what
were the problems that they had.
So that's why we decided to really
go for finding problems, finding out
what the needs of the people
were, what kind of ideas
they already had to solve
them, really to get a better
understanding of the
community, of the people,
of what was the issue at the
core of the city of Bandung.
We didn't really have
a lot of expectations.
This was kind of the first initiative
regarding crowdsourcing in Indonesia.
We [? really ?] hoped to
get a lot of submissions
because the mayor of Bandung really
has a lot of reach in the region.
So he is what in Asia is called a
key opinion leader, what we may call
in the Western world an influencer.
So he has a lot of Twitter followers.
So we expected to reach a
lot of people, but we never
expected to really get so many people
to participate, to join the discussion,
to submit their problems,
to submit their ideas,
and to contribute to this contest.
So we were really kind of overwhelmed
of how well this kind of initiative
worked in Indonesia.
Throughout the contest, we
collected more than 1,600 ideas
from all different kinds of topics--
from transportation, health
care, environment, education.
So the people really submitted
a lot of their problems
that they had and solutions that
they would like to see implemented.
Overall, more than 5,000 people
registered on the platform.
So really a big amount of the
citizens really got engaged here
and actually took the step
of taking part actively,
not just reading about it, not just
listening to what the mayor had to say.
There were about 16,000
people visiting the platform
during the time of the
contest, but 5,000 people
actually signed up and actively
engaged with the community.